HALF TO LOOK AT THE FOUR-PAGE
DOCUMENT.
>> Bret: MORE ON THIS WITH THE
PANEL.
THERE IS LITTLE EVIDENCE TONIGHT
UNITY IN PRESIDENT TRUMP'S FIRST
STATE OF THE UNION SPEECH.
JOHN ROBERTS LOOKS AT THE
PRESIDENT'S EFFORTS TO REACH
ACROSS THE AISLE.
>> GOOD EVENING.
MANY TIMES IN THE PAST,
PRESIDENTS HAVE HIT THE ROAD
IMMEDIATELY AFTER THE STATE OF
THE UNION ADDRESS DOES HAVE
THEIR POLICIES WERE INCLUDED IN
THE SPEECH.
PRESIDENT TRUMP PREFER TO STAY
HERE AT THE WHITE HOUSE AND THAT
THE THEMES OF HIS SPEECH
MARINADE FOR A WHILE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP GOT HIGH MARKS
FROM REPUBLICANS FOR A STATE OF
THE UNION ADDRESS, IN WHICH HE
EXTENDED AN OLIVE BRANCH TO
DEMOCRATS.
>> TWO NIGHTS I AM EXTENDING AN
OPEN HAND TO GIVE MEMBERS OF
BOTH PARTIES, DEMOCRATS AND
REPUBLICANS, TO PROTECT OUR
CITIZENS OF EVERY BACKGROUND,
COLOR, RELIGION, AND CREED.
>> DACA IS THE MOST URGENT
PRIORITY.
PRESIDENT TRUMP RELEASED A
COMPROMISE.
>> President Trump: DETAILED
PROPOSAL THAT SHOULD BE
SUPPORTED BY BOTH PARTIES HAS A
THEY WANT ABOUT WHERE OUR
COUNTRY GETS THE CRITICAL
REFORMS IT NEEDS AND MUST HAVE.
TO SPEAK WITH THE DEAL OFFERS A
PATH TO CITIZENSHIP, 1.8 MILLION
DREAMERS, THREE TIMES THE NUMBER
OF PEOPLE PRESIDENT OBAMA
PROTECTED.
MIGRATION IN THE VISA LOTTERY OR
SOMETHING THEY WON'T SWALLOW.
WHAT HE IS DOING BRINGS TEARS TO
CONCERNED ABOUT OUR DREAMERS.
>> President Trump: IT'S TIME
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP HOPES TO
BUILD SUPPORT FOR AN
INFRASTRUCTURE PROGRAM.
LEVERAGED BY PARTNERING WITH
PRIVATE SECTOR INVESTMENT TO
PERMANENTLY FIX THE
INFRASTRUCTURE DEFICIT.
>> DEMOCRATS ON THE RECORD
SUPPORTING INFRASTRUCTURE
RENEWAL BLEW A RASPBERRY AT
THAT, CALLING IT "PUNY."
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP TRIED TO PUT
A FRESH COAT OF PAINT ON A
FAILING PRESIDENCY.
ACKNOWLEDGE ITEMS LIKE A
HISTORIC LOW FOR
AFRICAN-AMERICAN UNEMPLOYMENT
AND CORPORATE BONUSES FOR
EMPLOYEES.
A BYPRODUCT OF TAX REFORM THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP HIGHLIGHTED
TODAY, INVITING WORKERS FROM
HAVE ANNOUNCED 3,000 BONUSES AND
IN SOME CASES EVEN MORE.
SOME HAVE GIVEN RAISES TO THE
MINIMUM WAGE UP TO 12, 13, 14
AND EVEN $15.
>> DIVISIONS CONTINUED TODAY
OVER THE WHITE HOUSE PLAN
RELEASE OF THE REPUBLICAN FISA
BRIAN KILMEADE, JOHN KELLY
SAYING THE SOONER IT IS OUT, THE
BETTER.
>> IT WILL BE RELEASED PRETTY
QUICK.
>> THERE WERE SOME MOMENTS
DURING THE STATE OF THE UNION
THAT BROUGHT TO BOTH SIDES TO
WHITE HOUSE, INCLUDING A
NORTH KOREAN DEFECTOR, WHO WAS
RAISED CRUTCHES BECAME THE FACE
OF NORTH KOREAN OPPRESSION.
LATE DEVELOPING NEWS WITH THE
FISA MEMO.
YESTERDAY BEFORE THE PRESIDENT
LEFT FOR THE STATE OF THE UNION,
FIVE CAREER OFFICIALS FROM THE
FBI CAME OVER TO DISCUSS THE
MEMO AND VIEW IT WITH THE CHIEF
OF STAFF, JOHN KELLY.
THE FBI OFFICIALS HAS SEEN AN
EARLIER VERSION OF IT.
THEY WERE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
I AM TOLD THE VERSION THEY SAW
LAST NIGHT HAVE BEEN CHANGED
SOMEWHAT FROM THE VERSION THEY
WERE CONCERNED ABOUT EARLIER.
YET THE FBI STILL WENT AHEAD AND
RELEASED THE STATEMENT OF